welcome to this video more habit what
habits have a plate mbsa i have from
finland so an enzo a bogo something else
what can I do what about the Queens
gambit let's play a rock-solid Queens
gambit for a change I was playing the
Catalan hmm ok let's let's do the
clothes catalan let's bishop d2b should
be seven it's a very very solid line
like is some setting up this kind of
information I'm not completely sure what
the most common move order is actually
do you play with Bishop a 60 it's 97 or
hmm I don't know ok let's let's just
play and see let's see later that it
cannot be terribly bad I think pusher
basics maybe 97's the more precise move
95 might might be an idea the only 95 ok
it's not doing it well at least with b3
plate I know that there is no Queen a
four or something like that hitting my
idea is simple rook c8 at c5 try to say
that the Queen on c2 is some in the way
of the is in the rooks in the rooks erm
line him ok so what does this mean he is
giving me Sephora hmm this is a common
common sacrifice this is type of this
type of fun but I'd rather want to take
when that's apology for already so lucky
for d takes e4 so he insists on the
whole thing
CMC 5c 5 is also an issue with my queen
on the aid if i take now twice he has
got 95 so tricky business um do I have
another some how do I have something
else let's say I have be 5b 5c 5
debatable but okay I don't really I
don't want to grab the pawn this this
really didn't look right to me okay here
actually if I've had if I wanted to play
c5a be five I shouldn't have played rook
c8 in the first place okay I suspect
he's going to play c5c 45 then I go
before night a4 maybe and then something
like we should be 5 & a 5 trying to keep
the Queen side this is also by rook c8
it's not working so well with be five
who in this situation after C 5 be 4 and
then later I go Bishop b5 and a5 the
rook is good on a to cover the a five
point after a three okay so he simply
wants to sacrifice this this ball no
matter what um okay takes I don't get it
to be honest this is really okay d takes
he wants to move the night it seems
Knight takes Knight takes pawn kicks I
don't get it okay I should I need to
play Knight takes pawn takes 95 maybe
sss idea on when Queen takes I just take
on c4 this this is just just not going
to work provide so he has to move the
night now somewhere 95 half Knight f6 92
might be a move
Jeff now he's thinking it probably maybe
he didn't didn't see in the first place
that after Queen e4d takes e4 he's just
losing c4 for nothing but 92 still seems
interesting I don't see a great reply to
that i mean i can't play f5 but this
looks f5 looks like a very shaky move
but maybe i should do it really why not
why not have five with threatening g5
here as loose as it looks but g5 we
should be three yeah g5 that's going to
hit you now yeah I know it looks it
looks exposed and everything but let me
let me think about it I can start with
III actually maybe this is the better
move III night f one night and then f
form this is what I want f4 he has no he
has no place for this Bishop to go to FY
killing killing the night
95 next unless something extraordinary
is happening takes takes bishop h3 might
be might be troublesome but still this
is a dead PCM by completely dead peace
so I always will be some summer in the
game I mean definitely let's see take
here Queen B 6 yeah probably the
alternative is queenie aid the ship we
have 79 f 7 s is not working at all and
tiie to Queen B 6 threatens e2 so we
cannot grab the exchange and I will play
King edge one anyway my point is are not
quite sure if I have to fear the lose of
dose of the exchange anyway in this
situation i don't think so i can play
Queen B 6 to keep the exchange but check
I mean I want to go to h5 here and I
don't want my queen on b6 somewhere on
the queenside I'm going to try to play
for a king a check on the King base them
based on them on the here on the
diagonal hives earning let's let's do
this immediately for Bishop e7 I can't
block with Bishop d5 but this is some
still interesting queen age 5 mm
this is a move I didn't expect at all
okay how I don't move the bishop I made
on age seven Wow
okay Queen B 6 was definitely easier
easier to play this is just a big mess
probably I mean I don't know it I have
some challenges yet for sure but it is
very difficult to say what this is
objectively especially considering the
time time situation
whoa okay I can play this intermediate
move I think check check it was a mostly
but not a bad one not a bad one check
check check mate well wow that was a
chaotic game what a chaotic game it
wasn't em probably not very necessary
okay so the computer actually wants to
take it that surprises me so okay I am
ok as usual I didn't calculate right
take stakes yeah this is definitely just
good for me I have Bishop t5 coming but
he has 95 of course yeah that is much
better this intends to check here and
after this white is in very good shape
so after Queen takes takes here 95 I
probably have to take and play something
like that which what is this yeah
probably something that is I had a
slightly better for white or close to
equal computers as equal but I rather be
why Chester ok this happened no f-fire
this is good for black I'm pretty sure
it is here now this yeah i mean the it
was much easier to play the Queen Queen
B 6 idea dear Queen B 6 is even is a
strongest young ok I understand now if
he has yes to do this move and now I can
just play normal stuff
keeping the pawns he has actually a bit
more solid it doesn't allow things like
that at all yeah here black is just
winning actually I go to c5 and incoming
challenge even know c4 is going to go
into drop yeah this this is not bad but
it is really messy yeah of course here
queen bee six is the normal move but
what a judge I wasn't sure what to do
from here maybe just play this position
here you know here i'm saving with the
exchange he has to play this and i go
here yeah like a well now that I when I
look at this it is it is pretty pretty
good right I mean white is playing
without the night this is the problem
those pawns are killing this piece and
hmm ok this will move us much better and
easier I guess I ok the comp still says
I'm winning here so I didn't really play
complete rubbish but but still ruki age
yeah I didn't I went for this for Bishop
e7 ok a ruse is six yeah and I'm winning
and fantastically enough computer gives
me a winning advantage Bishop c8 is
better though what a mess no here and
now this win so yeah ok I actually
suspected that I somehow screwed it up
but it doesn't seem to be the case I was
much better even with what I played had
similar things but I didn't didn't spoil
the advantage all together yeah half
tough game ok hope you liked it thanks
for watching